- On December 2, 1823,
U.S. President James Monroe
was giving his annual
State of the Union Address
to Congress when he threw
in a couple of remarks
about the United States' relationship
with the powers of Europe.
He said, "The American continents,
"by the free and independent condition
"which they have assumed and maintained,
"are henceforth not to
be considered as subjects
"for future colonization
by any European powers.
"In the wars of the European powers
"in matters relating to themselves
"we have never taken any part,
"nor does it comport
with our policy to do so.
"We owe it, therefore, to candor
"and to the amicable relations existing
"between the United States
and those powers to declare
"that we should consider
any attempt on their part
"to extend their system to
any portion of this hemisphere
"as dangerous to our peace and safety."
So, basically, in one fell swoop,
James Monroe told the
crowned heads of Europe
to stay out of the Americas.
He said, "As far as I'm concerned,
"the era of colonization is over."
Stop giving us the side-eye.
Stop looking at your
maps and trying to decide
where you might place
a little colony next.
No more European
colonization in the Americas.
What's more, don't interfere.
The Americas are the
United States' concern
so we don't want the powers of Europe
to meddle in any of the affairs
of Latin America or South America.
You can keep your system,
and by system, Monroe meant monarchy,
out of the Americas.
This is the hemisphere of democracy.
So, this is an incredibly bold statement.
Let's not forget here
that the United States
is not exactly a world power in 1823.
They could, at best, be
said to be a minor power,
even in the Americas.
The United States is not a
major world military power,
it's not a major world Navy power.
Let's remember that in this era,
having a strong Navy was
tantamount to being able
to take over the world.
They're kind of a second-rate nation
in a second-rate part of the world.
So, what was the response
when the United States
made this incredibly bold assertion
that they would not permit
any more colonization
or interference in the
Americas from Europe?
Mmm...
Crickets.
Nobody really cared.
To the established powers of Europe,
the United States was no
more than a little mosquito,
buzzing around, maybe
making a lot of noise,
a bit annoying, but pretty easy to swat.
No matter how much noise
the United States made,
the only thing that mattered to
the great powers of the
world was whether or not
the United States could
enforce the Monroe Doctrine,
which with such a weak military presence,
they certainly could not.
Nevertheless, the Monroe Doctrine became
a key facet of American foreign policy
throughout the 19th century
and into the 20th century.
It became a justification
for Manifest Destiny
and would play a major role
in the foreign policies
of Teddy Roosevelt and
Franklin Delano Roosevelt.
So, where did the Monroe
Doctrine come from?
Well, let's take a minute
to look at some of the
major world events of the time period
and the major players who brought
the Monroe Doctrine about.
All right, dateline 1820.
It has been a bad couple of
years for monarchy in Europe.
For one thing, the Napoleonic
Wars and the French Revolution
have been convulsing the powers of Europe
for several years.
By 1815, the Revolution
has more or less finished
and the monarchies of
Europe have been reinstated.
But, this revolutionary fervor
coming from the French Revolution,
coming also from the American Revolution,
has started to spread.
So, movements for independence
are now taking hold
in South America.
There's a Chilean
movement for independence,
Argentinian movement for independence,
Venezuelan movement for independence.
So, they've kind of
caught the democracy bug.
The people in the United
States are cheering
for their southern brethren, saying,
"Excellent work, picking up democracy,
"breaking away from
old-fashioned, monarchical,
"tyrannical Europe.
"We're totally on your side."
But it's easier to make an
independence movement happen
when the home country is
distracted with another war,
aka the Napoleonic Wars.
Once the Napoleonic Wars are over,
the monarchies of Europe start saying,
"Hmm, you know what?
"Since Spain is in
control of these nations,
"now Spain has the time and energy
"to consider maybe putting
down these revolutions."
So, they're no longer distracted by war,
and they have the
manpower and the bandwidth
to think about maybe trying
to reinstate, or secure,
Spanish rule in South
America where nations
have been in the process of revolution.
Now, we don't know the extent to which
Spain was actually planning on
putting these revolutions down,
but we do know that the
United States and England
were very concerned that the monarchies
of the continent-- France and Spain--
might join together and try to put down
all of these revolutions.
Now, wouldn't they want that?
Well, for the most part, it
kind of came down to markets.
If you think back to early
American colonial society,
the economic system was
known as mercantilism.
Mercantilism is the practice of
colonies kind of existing to
enrich the mother country.
So, all trade goes
through the home country.
That means that the home country
is going to be making sure
that the colonies are not trading
with any other international partners
because they want to be
the ones who are enriched
by the natural resources of the colonies.
So, when Chile and Argentina and Venezuela
revolt from Spain,
it means that their
markets are now opened up
to the United States and to England.
So, England and the United
States are not eager
to see these new nations be returned
to their colonial status because,
thanks to mercantilism, they're not going
to be able to trade with them anymore.
With this idea in mind,
the British Foreign Secretary,
a man named George Canning,
approached the American
Secretary of State,
John Quincy Adams,
and he said,
"Why don't we make a joint proclamation
"between the United
States and Great Britain
"saying that the powers of Europe
"should not interfere in the New World.?
And John Quincy Adams thought,
"Hmm, I'm not sure if I
like you British folks."
Remember that the War of
1812 had not taken place
too long beforehand.
The United States was not quite ready
to be friends with the United Kingdom yet.
And they were a little bit afraid that
if the United States made a
joint declaration with England
that it would seem a little bit like
a flea on the back of a rottweiler saying,
"Don't mess with us or we'll bite you!"
The United States didn't
have nearly the strength
to actually make an equal partnership
so it might have looked a little bit like
they were hiding behind the
British in a joint declaration,
but J.Q.A. thought this
actually still sounded
like a pretty good plan
so he floated the idea
to President James Monroe.
Now, there's kind of a
movement of nationalism
going on at this time
in the United States.
Even though the United States
didn't technically win the War of 1812,
they kind of felt like they had.
So, they're busy kind of creating
a new nationalist rhetoric
in the United States.
They're feeling pretty
good about themselves.
They stood up to their old
foe of Great Britain, and won.
Or, at the very least, didn't lose,
but to them it was kind of the same thing.
So, John Quincy Adams
crafts for James Monroe
what will become known
as the Monroe Doctrine.
Now, Monroe is not only concerned about
the possibility of European
powers coming down here
and trying to start fights with each other
over the fate of South America.
Monroe was also worried about Russia,
who had recently made some
territorial claims in Canada,
saying that their territory should come
all the way down there.
The Russians have started
putting some forts
on the coast of California,
close to modern day San Francisco.
So, Monroe sees the old
monarchical powers of Europe
sort of encroaching both from
the north and the south here.
And so, in 1823, he makes the announcement
of the Monroe Doctrine.
He says, "No more colonization.
"Russia, get out of there.
"And no more interference, in general.
"So, don't try to turn these new republics
"back into colonies under
the rule of monarchies.
"In fact, just keep your monarchy
"out of our hemisphere altogether."
Monroe makes this statement
completely outside
of the relationship
with the United Kingdom
so it doesn't have this kind
of riding on the coattails
feeling of being allied with Britain.
But nevertheless, the only
way that the United States
can actually count on the
Monroe Doctrine being enforced
is because the British Navy
is so incredibly powerful.
I'm going to draw a very bad boat here.
Nobody who heard about the
Monroe Doctrine thought,
"Ah, man, we better not make
the United States angry."
What they thought was,
"Ah, man, we better not make
the British Empire angry."
Because they knew that the British Navy,
which wanted neutrality of the seas,
which wanted to be able to continue
to have these trade relationships
with new nations in South America,
would defend the neutrality
and the independence
of South America by proxy,
and by doing so, kind of
enforce the Monroe Doctrine.
So, this is interesting.
You could think of this as
being a little bit weaselly
on the part of Monroe,
declaring that the Americas
should remain free of
the influence of Europe,
but counting on the United
Kingdom to enforce it.
Or you could think of it as perhaps
a brilliant policy maneuver.
I don't know.
Certainly, the nations of
South America and Latin America
appreciated this
declaration of independence
for the Americas coming
from the United States,
but they certainly knew
that it was more about
the United States making sure that
they, themselves, were
protected than wanting
to have a real equal
partnership with South America.
So, the Monroe Doctrine
really didn't amount to much
for most of the 19th century.
It was certainly a justification
as the United States
continued to push west
in their quest of Manifest Destiny,
but it will become increasingly important
in the 20th century as the United States
steps onto the world
stage with things like
the Spanish American War,
under the auspices of William McKinley,
and making famous Theodore
Roosevelt, saying that
the Caribbean is the province
of the United States,
and the nations of Latin
America and South America.
They're only to be dealt with
through the United States.
So, you can see the Monroe Doctrine as
a very early expression
of the United States'
intention to become a world power
and to be the leading
and most powerful nation
in the Americas.
And you can also see it as an expression
of American isolationism,
which will really be
the leading aspect of
American foreign policy
up until the Spanish American War.
As early as George
Washington's Farewell Address,
Washington expressed the
view that the United States
should just not get involved
in the business of Europe.
That that would only lead to heartbreak.
While the Monroe Doctrine
is now kind of taking
not only that idea that the United States
should not become involved
in the affairs of Europe,
but also turning it around and saying that
Europe should not become involved
in the affairs of the Americas,
drawing an even stronger barrier
between the old world and the new.